bottes beiges et gants ils étaient plus
d'une centaine à pied d'oeuvre ce samedi
ses bénévoles plantes être échelle pour
reboiser la forêt de sainte apolline
quand je vois toutes les actualités va
j'ai envie de que ça change quelque
chose de durable aussi quelque chose
qu'on peut laisser aux générations
futures
donc ça c'est ça a du sens durant ce
week-end près de 3000 arbres ont été
plantés sur une parcelle de 15 hectares
deux essence principal accompagné
d'autres armes pour favoriser leurs
pouces
on va mettre les chaînes au milieu du
carré autour on va faire un périmètre a
que des boulots des pins sylvestres ou
des charmes qui vont avoir une fonction
de gainage d'ailleurs qui vont créer de
l'ombre au tour des chaînes et les
chaînes donc vont être contraint de
pousser un petit peu en hauteur pour
cette action les yvelines se sont
associés à reforestation une entreprise
qui intervient dans 20 pays
la plantation vise à aider la
régénération dans certains cas la
régénération naturelle ne se fait pas
tout seul cercle n'y a pas de nouvelle
génération qui arrive est donc là il
faut l'accompagner
là on est sur une première vague sur sur
l'année et demie de 3000 arbres mais on
compte bien aller bien au delà je parle
de la forêt de sainte apolline bien sûr
mais pas uniquement sur tous les espaces
départementaux la forêt de sainte
apolline est un massif de 300 hectares à
dominante feuillus surplombant le
plateau de versailles elle est gérée par
le département les yvelines possède 36%
des espaces forestiers sur son
territoire as tu lui envoie un baiser
ah bah voilà